- Guten Morgen, Inge.
- Guten Morgen, Nico!
Wie siehst du denn aus?
- Wie bitte?
- Ich meine … Hast du den Pullover gekauft?
Ist der neu?
- Nein, das ist kein neuer Pullover.
Der Pullover ist von Sebastian.
Meine Sachen sind …
- ... in deiner Tasche, jaja.
Aber der Pullover ist viel zu groß.
Und die Farbe? Ist das jetzt in?
- Das weiß ich nicht.
- Ich finde den Pullover nicht so schön.
Du brauchst neue Sachen zum Anziehen.
Du brauchst ein schickes Hemd und einen
warmen Pullover und eine schöne Hose.
Ach Nico, kannst du gleich Brötchen kaufen?
- Ja, gerne!
- Das ist lieb von dir!
Kauf bitte dunkle Brötchen.
Die schmecken am besten.
- Uhum.
- Nico!
- Selma!
- Ist das …?
- Deine Tasche?